qualcuno ha detto che
la vita può essere capita solo
andando indietro cioè guardando il
nostro passato ma fondamentalmente deve
essere vissuta andando in avanti
questo è molto scontato molto odio come
tante frasi simili a quella che vi ho
appena citato che ci hanno detto nella
nostra vita abbiamo ricevuto abbiamo
letto su un libro però poi quando
andiamo a vedere anche le cose più
scontate metterle in pratica diventa un
pochino difficile andare avanti ma ma
come in che modo cioè a me non ha
insegnato nessuno ad andare avanti in un
modo piuttosto che in un altro ho dovuto
imparare io strada facendo
ora immagino a questa scena un ragazzo
ha davanti a sé due donne una è la donna
dei suoi sogni la donna che ha
desiderato per anni la donna
caratterialmente perfetta fisicamente la
sua donna ideale proprio quella che
immaginava dall'altra parte a una donna
con cui non andrebbe mai una donna che
caratterialmente ha proprio il suo posto
una donna che fisicamente non gli piace
secondo te
se tutte e due queste donne
acconsentono
questo non fa le andrebbe o con quale
dovrebbe andare è sicuramente la
risposta ovvia anche qui a con quella
che è di suo gradimento
giusto
però purtroppo non accade sempre così
esiste un principio in fisica e che
viene chiamato terzo principio della
dinamica ad ogni azione c'è una reazione
ovvero se noi mettiamo due le nostre
mani su un muro e spingiamo più
spingiamo è più il muro sembra spingere
verso di noi e questo principio anche a
un suo ha una sua logica e da molto
scontato se ci pensi
però poi nella vita ci troviamo molto
spesso a non agire è quello che è
capitato a me e per tantissimi anni
nella mia adolescenza soprattutto quando
sono arrivato alla scuola media e quindi
ho avuto il passaggio che mentali medie
e da lì cambiando anche quartiere mi
sono voluto ripresentare con una nuova
veste di un ragazzo introverso timido
provavo a farmi vedere come l'esatto
contrario perché mi sembrava quella
un'immagine di un ragazzo più figo da
vedere
aveva una ragazza che mi piaceva
tantissimo e come tanti purtroppo non
riuscivo a dimostrare a questa ragazza
il mio amore verso di lei
e la vedevo passare dicevo che adesso le
dico qualcosa e non partivo la rivedevo
che domani a scuola
arrivo crea un momento alla ricreazione
le dico qualcosa e poi la li vedevo
passare e non diciamo nulla e questo
andato avanti per mesi e poi per anni e
non è accaduto solo con questa ragazza
accaduto anche con le opportunità
lavorative perché molte mi spaventavano
allora dovevo prendere il treno al volo
e il treno lasciapassare vedevo che
passava un treno ne passava un altro
questo mi capitava con le amicizie
perché ho paura di soffrire ho paura di
essere tradito di nuovo qualche ragazzo
andando avanti con l'età e poi anche
esperienze come viaggi nuove conoscenze
nuove culture ho sempre avuto paura ad
esempio anche di parlare in pubblico io
ho vissuto con la convinzione che io non
dovessi disturbare io non devo
disturbare devo passare inosservato così
non rischio di sbagliare
la paura era davvero forte ed è questa
sensazione di paura che tutti noi almeno
una volta nella vita abbiamo vissuto la
sensazione che c'è proprio prima del
momento in cui dobbiamo agire
è una sensazione mista a paura
indecisione e anche proiezione negativa
di quello che potrebbe accadere e quando
siamo proprio immersi in questo dialogo
interno che ci dice no fermo sarà una
cavolata no non lo fare no ai rischi
potrebbero essere questi potresti morire
potrebbe crollare tutto potrebbe poi ne
parleranno i tuoi amici ti prenderanno
in giro iniziata ad andare velocissimo
ma il cervello che a volte invece
bollentissimo solo quando vuole lui e in
quel momento invece bravissimo a
metterci un ansia addosso incredibile
che ti paralizza a me ad esempio mi ge
lava le mani le mani congelate se mi
davi la mano in quei momenti di tensione
io ero un blocco di ghiaccio e non
riuscivo ad agire cioè rimanevo fermo e
vedevo appunto questa ragazza che poi se
l'è portata via uno dei miei migliori
amici e tutte le altre cose che erano
tutte opportunità che poi mi rendevo
conto
dopo
essere svanite nel nulla e poi ci
troviamo a dire frasi come se tornassi
indietro farei così se avesse avuto il
coraggio quel giorno o una delle più
gettonate
sarebbe stato bello
sarebbe stato bello io questa frase me
la sono ripetuta troppe volte talmente
tante volte che dopo un po deciso di
iniziare ad odiarla odiano così tanto da
trovare un modo per creare dei
cambiamenti
c'è una frase bellissima che dice osare
perdere momentaneamente la propria stata
la strada non osare è perdere se stessi
ed è proprio quello che capitava a me
non osando sto perdendo me stesso perché
non stavo dando valore alla persona più
importante che c'era in quel momento
stavo dando più spazio a delle paure che
molto spesso erano illusorie finte
fittizie create dalla mia mente cose che
immaginavo che poi non sono mai accadute
realmente quindi osare significa agire
e agire prima di ragionare perché se
iniziamo a ragionare diventa un problema
mi trovavo a bali con un gruppo di
studenti che frequentano i miei i miei
percorsi avanzati in questi viaggi
ovviamente li porta a fare delle sfide e
andammo a fare questo trekking
un'escursione assite ma non posso
migliosi in mezzo alle risaie verdi
famosissime di bali e questo trekking
durava quattro ore oramo circa a metà ad
un certo punto la giornata era
bellissima vediamo da lontano una serie
di nuvole veramente incavola tenere ma
proprio nere fitte che si avvicinano
verso di noi la guida ovviamente che ci
stava accompagnando in questo tecnici
dice quelle lì sono le cattive perchè in
questi paesi tropicali come sapete
cambia il metodo in modo veramente
repentino e ci dice che quelle nuvole
stanno arrivando da noi quindi
probabilmente prenderemo un
bell'acquazzone anche perché in quei
paesi quando inizia a piovere
piove davvero e piove per tante ore vedo
nel gruppo rom una ventina di persone
vedo nelle facce delle persone il
terrore oddio come faremo o lo zaino il
cellulare inizia a preoccuparti perché
hai tutte le due cose addosso non vuoi
bagnarti bagnarti nel bel mezzo di un
trekking dove potrebbe anche iniziare a
fare freddino perché comunque non era
piena estate quindi poteva anche potevi
anche sentire il brividino inizia un po
a terrorizzarci l'idea ad un certo punto
più le nuvole si avvicinavano più
vedevamo la pioggia a cadere che si
avvicinava più ci avvicinavamo ad un
fiume ad un certo punto arriviamo tutti
a ridosso di questo fiume la guida ci
guarda e ci dice dobbiamo attraversarlo
e io chiedo alla guida ma dobbiamo
attraversarlo a piedi cioè dobbiamo
immergerci nell'arco ad attraversare il
fiume si c al massimo arriverà la vita
quindi togliete cellulari dalle tasche e
attraversiamo il fiume e dobbiamo tenere
le scarpe sì sì assolutamente tenete le
scarpe perfette mi giro e dico ai
ragazzi ragazzi dobbiamo attraversare il
fiume i ragazzi come io sì sito che
attraversa il fiume tra una figata
vedete la vita è già entrata entriamo
tutti in acqua e si crea quando fai
qualcosa che va un po fuori dagli schemi
quell'energia particolare che il
contrario della sensazione di cui
parlavo prima
mista a paura e indecisione quella
sensazione dove sei tu che stai
decidendo di fare qualcosa di folle e lo
stai facendo cioè sta immergendo i tuoi
piedi con tutte le scarpe e calzini
all'interno di un fiume nel bel mezzo di
un trekking a bali si è creato un
energia one a gente che urlava con i
bastoni in mano che si schizzavano la
acqua nel giro di trenta secondi il
morale e l'entusiasmo lo stato d'animo
del gruppo è totalmente cambiato abbiamo
attraversato il fiume abbiamo continuato
il trekking è arrivata la pioggia e non
ci eravamo dimenticati della pioggia ma
quando è arrivata la pioggia a quel
punto noi eravamo altre persone perché
noi avevamo agito ancor prima di subire
quindi osare significa agire prima di
ragionare agire prima di pensare a tutte
le conseguenze negative questo non sto
dicendo che dobbiamo essere
inconsapevole di quello che facciamo è
ovvio che dobbiamo pensare anche ad una
strategia per non rischiare la vita in
alcuni casi è quello la nostra migdal è
bravissima a fare questo svolgere questo
compito dobbiamo però buttarci perché
altrimenti se pensiamo troppo o
diventiamo maniaci di perfezionismo o
rimaniamo imbambolati e la vita ci passa
davanti e purtroppo almeno quella che
ricordiamo è una sola poi ci creda la
reincarnazione va bene ma è una sola e
dobbiamo godercela quindi da questa
lezione ho imparato che ci sono
delle modalità in cui siamo noi a
scegliere delle modalità in cui è la
vita a scegliere e lo facciamo questa
scelta attraverso tre zone di
cambiamento la prima zona di cambiamento
e una zona di sicurezza ovvero dove noi
aspettiamo che sia la vita a decidere
per noi quindi abbiamo paura di lasciare
il vecchio anche se un lavoro che non ci
piace una relazione distruttiva o
qualsiasi altra cosa preferiamo rimanere
in quella che gli americani chiamano la
zona di comfort però come dico sempre
questa è stata un
un'idea che ho avuto ad un certo punto
perché leggendo tutti questi libri di
crescita personale tutti ripetevano
questa storia della della zona di
comfort ad un certo punto sulla mia
pelle ho scoperto che la zona dicono
esiste perché cure trovava a rimanere
nella mia zona di confort più mi rendevo
conto che la vita anche se tu non vuoi
anche se tu riesca a rimanere al sicuro
butta fuori dalla zona comfort quindi a
questo punto ha detto ok se comunque la
vita mi butta fuori allora forse doveva
essere io ad andare fuori dalla zona
comfort anche perché in questa leva di
zona di cambiamento che la sicurezza la
leva il cambiamento è il dolore ovvero
noi decidiamo di cambiare quando
proviamo tanto dolore quindi quando
inizia anche un periodo di sofferenza la
solita gocciolina che fa traboccare il
vaso però scoperto anche che non
dobbiamo arrivare a questo punto ok io
in diverse situazioni della mia vita
sono dovuto arrivare a questo punto cioè
sono dovuto arrivare all'estremo per
riuscire a prendere una decisione perché
non avevo ancora queste consapevolezze
poi c'è una seconda zona di cambiamento
che è una zona di necessità ovvero
cambiamo per necessità e quindi valuto
la mia vita le aree importanti della mia
vita e capisco attraverso uno studio
anche di coaching se vogliamo dove
valuto area per area alle cose che devo
migliorare le cose che devo correggere
decido dove voglio potenziare e quindi
prendo delle decisioni e poi compio
delle azioni in tale direzione
questa è una leva il cambiamento molto
più efficace perché non aveva il
cambiamento che parte da un bisogno
quindi ho bisogno di crearmi questa
nuova competenza allora mi butto io
nello sconforto e cambio e quindi è un
cambiamento che parte da noi siamo noi
che entriamo nel fiume e non è la
pioggia che arriva e ci mandato talmente
in crisi la terza la zona di cambiamento
e non sono ancora più elevata che parte
dall intuizione quindi accede al potere
dell'universo capisci da te ascoltando
il tuo cuore ascoltando la tua anima
cosa è giusto e cosa è sbagliato e
quindi riesce a generare anche ben s nel
mondo infatti la leva al cambiamento qui
è contributo cioè voglio contribuire al
benessere del mondo quindi faccio cose
che mi portano fuori dalla mia zona
comfort per lasciare un segno anche
perché se noi non lasciamo fuori dalla
nostra zona di comfort non aggiungiamo
valore alla vita degli altri non
aggiungiamo valore all universo e quindi
perché viviamo ricordate ricordiamoci
che tutto ciò che esiste
in natura è destinato ad evolvere
destinato a crescere ciò che non cresce
ferisce quindi muore e quindi scompare e
allora
se l'unico modo per crescere andare
fuori dalla zona confort bisogna andare
fuori controllo
e infatti ad un certo punto
ho capito che per crescere per evolvere
dove proprio per questo andare fuori
controllo cioè crearmi delle abitudini
che mi portassero fuori dal mio
controllo
quindi dalle cose che potesse
controllare avevo bisogno di farlo il
più spesso possibile tanti anni fa avevo
iniziato a studiare il benessere
quindi tutte le strategie che potessero
migliorare la salute del mio corpo
soprattutto quella di mio padre perché
stava male ha avuto un infarto gli hanno
dato due anni di vita
scoprì la doccia fredda i benefici
dell'acqua fredda e quindi anche della
crioterapia
provai questa doccia fredda fu terribile
cioè girare la manopola sul freddo in
pieno inverno è veramente terrificante
però se sentina il mio corpo e
soprattutto nella mia mente una reazione
positiva
ho detto io sono andato fuori controllo
in questo momento cioè ho fatto qualcosa
che nessuno farebbe si sta facendo una
bella doccia carta burgic la manopola
freddo wow che sensazione ho fatto dieci
secondi ho urlato alla fine mi sono
sentito un guerriero quindi un guerriero
è una doccia di casa wow posso sfidarmi
ogni giorno iniziato a fare questa
doccia fredda da 30 secondi sono passato
ad un minuto minuto e mezzo due minuti
dieci minuti di doccia fredda poi
iniziato a scalare montagne fare kite
surf insomma tante cose corso maratona
che che potessero stimolarmi ad andare
fuori controllo viaggiato nel mondo ho
iniziato a parlare in pubblico io mi
vergognavo anche a parlare davanti a tre
persone e questa è diventata una mia
filosofia di vita andare fuori controllo
e portare fuori controllo anche gli
altri ad esempio i miei clienti perché
so che se ci alleniamo ad andare fuori
controllo poi quando la vita ci mandano
fuori controllo per che accadrà noi
sapremo gestire in modo molto più
efficace con le dinamiche
ci sono tante cose che ci possono tenere
fermi il problema che abbiamo in molti
purtroppo è che avevo io molto radicato
dentro di me il controllo questo bisogno
di controllare tutto e tutti
il partner
il lavoro e quindi il rischio di
sbagliare sostanzialmente il rischio di
essere giudicati e per fare questo
appunto non viviamo la nostra vita ed è
un peccato mi trovavo racconto questa
cosa e poi chiudo perché vedo che il
tempo è già finito
mi trovavo a rieti era andato ad un
battesimo di un parente e e vado a
trovare mia nonna che purtroppo da un po
di anni ea casa sulla sedia a rotelle
non può più camminare non ci vede bene
non ci sente bene insomma a 93 anni
quindi come tutti gli anziani è arrivata
a questo livello di salute
insomma vado da mio nonno a trovarle
come al solito quando le chiedono come
stai e che a casa è difficile sono sola
nessuno mi viene a trovare meno male che
si è passato ora dico nonna ma se ci
fosse una cosa fosse un genio della
lampada che potesse esaudire un
desiderio se ci fosse una cosa che pure
tu volessi fare cosa cosa vorresti fare
col quale ha un sogno nel cassetto
insomma inizia a dire voglio tornare a
cucinare gli gnocchi o cosa
irrealizzabile le dissi non ha una cosa
che si può fare se voglio venire a
trovare te a malta perché io vivo a
malta e di con veramente nonna figata fa
sì sì voglio venire a trovare ea malta
probabilmente lei pensava che io la
prendesse un po così sullo scherzo nel
giro di cinque minuti io avevo già
comprato il biglietto per lei per mia
madre per mia cugina che è arrivata poco
dopo e per mia zia e allora la mia nonna
inizio da dire ops questo chi l'ha fatto
davvero l'ho mandata fuori controllo e
ad un certo punto il giorno dopo io sono
andato via nell'entusiasmo quindi
andiamo tutti a malta che figata
il giorno dopo mi chiama mia zia e
cerali con la mia nonna e mi dice da
anni certo nonna che deve dirti una cosa
importante te la passo nei nove fadani
ho paura perché ho pensato adesso che
devo prendere l'aereo e non ho mai preso
l'aereo una vita la cina va bene ma sarà
una figata dai pensa che sta venendo a
malta poi non succede niente lì saranno
gli steward che si prenderanno cura di
te cioè queste cose vengono fatte
quotidianamente le per loro sono sono
normali ma io ho paura ora pure allora
l'ho ascoltata un po nelle sue paure le
sono stato vicino a un certo punto mi
dice dani ma io voglio andare fuori
controllo ho capito se devo morire tanto
ormai sono arrivata vicino alla fine se
devo morire
preferisco farlo sull'aereo mentre lang
attuare della malta ecco mia nonna quel
giorno mi ha dato una grandissima
lezione che avrei voluto imparare tanti
anni prima però poi alla fine tutte le
rinunce che ho dovuto fare una vita mi
sono tornate con gli interessi dal
momento che ho capito perché non è mai
troppo tardi per prendere in mano la
propria vita allora non bisogna pertanto
paura di morire ma piuttosto di vivere
davvero questo è diventato un mio mantra
andare fuori controllo mi viene davvero
ogni giorno della mia vita e così oggi
ho realizzato la vita dei miei sogni
aiuto tante persone a fare altrettanto
grazie